hey youtubers it's Charlie so there was
a big convention over the weekend and
the stars of the flash we're talking
about season 3 flash point things so
this is gonna be all about that Carlos
the actor the plays Cisco was saying
there's gonna be huge changes but he
said not in a bad way so I think they're
gonna make some changes from the flash
point comic book storyline I mean
besides the obvious changes they're not
gonna have Batman on the flash so there
are certain characters from flashpoint
paradox that you will not see on the
flash season 3 but the main arc of
flashpoint is just that you Barry goes
back prevents his mother from being
murdered and it causes complete chaos
with a timeline everything changes in a
catastrophic terribly bad world ending
scenario in the comics Barry going back
in time to save his mother pretty much
leads to the end of the world the way
Cisco was talking about it is that
things will change in a dramatic way but
it's not going to be as dire
consequences as the comic book scenario
so just expect dramatic changes from the
comic book storyline but there were some
flash arrow actors that have died off on
the TV show that talked about showing up
on earth 2 again so we'll talk about
that in a sec but let's talk about the
main characters first what about Barry
it sounds like he's still gonna have
powers I don't think the people would
watch a flash TV show where the flash
can't be the flash for a certain amount
of time maybe they'll be a couple times
when he loses his powers briefly but
he'll get them back I think we can all
agree that everyone wants to see the
flash doing things that the flash does
in the comics but of all the things that
are changing next season Barry will
probably be the least change because
he'll be a remnant from the original
timeline like oh my god what have I done
the futures completely changed whereas
when it goes back to the future nobody
else will know the difference
although Cisco's ability allows him to
sense changes in the timeline
so if Cisco is still a metahuman it
still has his vibe powers which I think
that he will he'll know that something's
different but he won't totally
understand what's going on right away
helping him out as always will be most
of the main cast they pretty much said
most of the main cast is coming back I
know after the finale Tom Cavanagh was a
question mark he was one of my big picks
to come back just because he's such an
amazing actor
he's been made cast he's so integral
it's a team flash and I figured they'd
find some way to bring him back
they didn't say which version of him
would be coming back if he'd be earth to
harrison wells or if he'd be the
original version of harrison wells
it's actually the version we've seen the
least of if you remember in season one
we saw you bard dawn basically absorb
his DNA just so that he could hide out
for all those years wearing him like a
meat suit so we might actually see that
original version of Harrison wells but
just to be determined so I know a lot of
you are asking if those earth-2
characters that we saw so much of last
season are gonna come back does that
mean berry changing the past isn't going
to completely change all the stuff that
happened with zoom during season two is
it gonna reset the timeline I think it's
a little early to make predictions about
that but I feel like they're not totally
gonna trample on all the adventures the
team flash had all the victories that
they had I think the relationship will
just shift and they'll be like one or
two things that are catastrophic aliy
bad as a result like the whole point of
the flashpoint paradox arc is very
coming to terms with the idea that you
can't save everyone and you just have to
be okay with that so what'll probably
happen is is he goes back saves his
mother and he's like you know you're
fine I'm not gonna hurt you he goes back
to the future and we see his mom for a
good portion of the season she's just
like the kind benevolent figure that you
always thought that she would be like
just a great mom in the way that Henry
Allen was a great dad
but because Jon Wesley Shipp is Jay
Garrick now maybe that means that Henry
Allen ends up dying at some later date
so it saves his mother but his father
dies so I think whatever changes they
make to the comic book flashpoint
storyline the message will still be the
same Barry will get to the end of the
season and realize that he can't always
save everyone and I think the biggest
question I know a lot of you guys have
is does that mean that dead people like
Eddie will come back it's totally
possible the actors that were at this
comic book convention we're talking a
lot about blacks IRA and Katie Cassidy's
character like wouldn't it be awesome
for her to come back and have a
crossover with arrow obviously the
actors don't have the whole story like
they're just now meeting with the
producers to find out what's going on
next season because they're still
writing it they haven't written all the
episodes yet they're still deciding what
the major arcs are gonna be but if
they're gonna do a big four-way cross
over I think they're gonna try and find
a way to bring back all the really big
characters that you tend to see every
single season so that means some of the
dead earth-2 characters like earth to
Deadshot I know we talked about how the
Suicide Squad in the movies basically
killed off the Suicide Squad on the TV
show but Deadshot is like the funny
bumbling police captain of earth two so
we might see him again I
we'll definitely see Katie Cassidy come
back just because everyone was like oh
my god metahuman Black Canary this is so
amazing even though they didn't call her
Black Canary she's black and airy in
everything but name pretty much but what
about killer frost earth to killer frost
is dead
they might choose to make Caitlyn a
metahuman we will see killer frost one
way or another whether she comes from
our earth or she comes from another
earth remember we have the multiverse we
have an infinite number of planets that
we can visit speaking of which
supergirls earth I know everyone's still
wondering are they gonna combine her
earth with earth one now that she's on
the CW with all the other shows no one
associated with the show no the
producers have said anything about it so
until we actually hear some news I'm
just gonna assume she's still gonna be
on a separate earth they're gonna have
to travel via wormhole to get to her but
we will see the four night crossover so
that will probably be a multiverse
spanning story which will probably
involve a multiverse villain we might
see crime syndicate we might see them
involved in some sort of larger legends
of tomorrow just a society story just a
society that's actually a whole separate
thing they explained that legends of
tomorrow season two is gonna look
completely different from season one
different scenarios different problems
going to different places so the best
example that I can think of that would
be like American Horror Story where
season to season it's a completely
different story with different
characters and it doesn't look anything
like the season before but isn't that
just a funny idea legends of tomorrow
Murder House legends of tomorrow freak
show if you guys don't know what
American Horror Story is don't worry
about it it's just an anthology show
that changes a lot from season to season
that's the way they're talking about
legends of tomorrow it's gonna be an
anthology show so think of it as like a
comic book volume and then the heroes go
off and do something else the next
season but speaking of Justice Society
and I've talked about Jay Garrick on the
flash season two he'll definitely come
back to guest star but I'm also kind of
expecting them to borrow him for that
big four night Justice Society crossover
just because he's such a big Justice
Society character it'd be silly not to
use him but if you remember how much
Henry Allen showed up during the first
half of the flash season one he was
there for a couple episodes I think it's
gonna be the same deal with Jay Garrick
from Earth 3 like the Jay Garrick that
we met at the end of flash season two
he'll probably come back and help every
once in a while but I'm not expecting
him every single episode I don't think
that he's supposed to be a series
regular but let me know in the comments
what do you guys want them to do if
they're not gonna do the exact comic
book storyline from flashpoint paradox
how do you want them to mess with the
characters I think everybody would like
to see a metahuman version of Caitlyn on
earth one but don't worry even if they
don't go that route will probably see
some version of killer frost but gorilla
grodd king shark pretty much all the
hits any of the biggest characters from
the previous season like the big fan
favorites they'll totally be back at
least once during the season they
haven't said a whole lot about the
villain yet they'll probably cast that
person during the summer but supposedly
it's not gonna be a metahuman like I
said in my season 3 predictions video
what they might end up doing is giving
him a comic-book name and just making
him a non-powered version of that
character if that's gonna be the case
but if you are wondering don't worry
I'll be doing flash bonus videos all
summer there'll be all kinds of DC comic
book Marvel comic book stuff going on so
it is gonna be an awesome summer and
they've actually already started writing
the flash season 3 we're in the middle
of convention season which means the
actors are gonna be talking about the
next season so we might actually get
some pretty cool info dumps in the next
couple of months so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and there is a new
round of the DC giveaway
don't worry I'll still keep doing the
giveaway all summer all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video she was a $20
Amazon gift card just like normal so
there's any flash bonus videos that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments below while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for my big flash season 3
predictions video and you can click here
to learn about the new backstory for
Brienne the gorge are Martin just wrote
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight